foreign
welcome back to CBS morning's our earth
365 series explores the health of our
planet year round and we all want a
healthy planet right now we're following
the latest extreme weather that's
lashing California right now with that
torrential rain and snow you've seen the
pictures it's just the latest in a
series of storms going back to New
Year's Eve known as Adam
atmospheric Rivers they are long did I
say that right got it atmospheric Rivers
they are long narrow bands of moisture
from the tropics senior National and
environmental correspondent Ben Tracy
tells us more about this phenomenon and
whether it's enough to end California's
devastating drought
its weather Whiplash in the west from
devastating drought to days of deluge a
parade of atmospheric Rivers is
barreling on Shore this conveyor belt of
moisture also called the Pineapple
Express can carry up to 15 times the
volume of the Mississippi River in each
storm system this does feel like we're
on the express train part of this we are
on the express train for sure it's been
storm after storm but they're very
important the main source for moisture
for the for the western part of the U.S
especially the coastal States
scientists say climate change is making
extremes more extreme droughts are drier
and these sorts of winter storms are
wetter because a warmer atmosphere holds
more moisture
so when it rains it pours that's
refilling California's critically low
reservoirs in piling up snowpack in the
Sierra which is now more than 200
percent of normal our snowpack is
actually off to one of its best start in
the past 40 years
but in Los Angeles which Imports more
than half its water supply from Northern
California and the drought-ravaged
Colorado River all this rain is a
torrent of wasted opportunity so none of
this water is going to do us any good
here very very little of it most of the
area's storm water is funneled into the
concrete-lined LA River and flushed into
the ocean in effort to prevent flooding
LA's prized possession real estate
we capture about 20 percent of our storm
water between the storm last week and
the storm that's happening now I bet
we're going to see 20 25 30 billion
gallons of water just going out the LA
River into the ocean L.A county is now
spending nearly 300 million dollars a
year to capture more storm water
including so-called spreading grounds
where runoff can seep into the soil
helpful during the prolonged drought is
this a drought Buster is this a drought
denter do we have any idea we are
getting exactly what we need to bust the
drought but we still have two-thirds of
the wet season to come and we could get
very little precipitation you know it's
very unpredictable
unpredictability is now the one thing we
can count on for CBS mornings I'm Ben
Tracy in Los Angeles